yeah as the wind welcome to this video
playing Korean cuffs who lives and play
them for a long time it feels I have for
a couple of games on the record 10 13
with a pretty good school but I haven't
played in for quite a while I feel so
listen we placed hey what does he play
bit of a weird Hedgehog style of opening
this is does not this is not really good
to be honest but let's see what happens
so let's put pressure on the porn I
should a three it's probably right
Jeff d6 is quite a problem okay so he's
just giving me this pawn the unprotected
a3 rook is something to watch out wrong
yep here we have one one particular case
it shouldn't give it away okay but
what's going on here luke t 8 is around
the corner hmm and it's actually a
little bit of a problem I cannot just
play ok to war zone
[Music]
hmm so blacks position is playable so
now okay let's go back then yeah Queenie
to has to be played I guess and now this
is not not not great maybe here I would
love to double on the D file the Queen
ish is not so great that on d5 it's good
that it takes to be seven permit and I
rather have a look in front like if you
move the queen that I will be five or
something or here look to d6 intending
would be six
intending move d 7 you have gotten some
very nice activity but i blundered this
porn oh my god why did I do that that
was humid that gives away almost
anything almost everything not anything
I think is correct so um what do we have
here this one probably
ok so still some pressure on your seven
probably difficult difficult to maintain
maintain enough him say a way to prevent
a fall and still maybe a seven prevent a
form and I'll Queen you five keeping the
pressure on that seven and try to win
this porn so wonderful which is nice but
not necessarily winning okay
your koon ending is very good for what I
can take up seven what am I doing here
ah Christ I can just take take that
bloody pawn and win check check check
check
but you know it screen to see five and
then push the pause check time wording
page four I have 27 son okay let's see
here and then it's got Queen Queen 25 I
guess it anyway okay yes well let's
little bit unlucky check check check
check I just have 20 second chances
probably the issue check
okay it's got another single check here
check check check check check check
check check check check check yeah I can
get a camel doin here unfortunately
check bit of a shame check Graham Alfred
game the wrong yeah of course it was
clean and he was totally winning but I'm
nice border check and when you got this
age 5 business here age 40 here jae seok
winter e6 and then be six okay yeah this
is what I have to do I like here he s
looking somewhere and then they sell
these kind of little things are not so
easy for me at least to do an object
game and this is it covers this so this
is all nonsensical and the bee pollen
just goes home yeah bit of a shame that
the potential to me when I go yes and it
was pretty is pretty bad but somehow
flex like hang on him maybe at this was
for precise check it is happened first
yea year 95 is not so great Queenie
seven saves at film so I have to have to
play the sims will just extremely weak
porn that I will very likely win yeah he
is getting it back and then now why does
just jumped very slightly better ok this
was a joke really I completely blunder
85 yahoo gay 4head widest
a lot more comfortable Jen Jen yeah I
think I did this and this I said some
problems Quincy five was better on cam
yes check the Queen ending is just
winning Ike we have 70 missed em that is
the immediate end of the game basically
yeah anyway thanks for watching